[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on in your world
Kate Hi there um so I I have a bit of
debt um and I'm kind of new to listening
to the Ramy show and I'm so glad that I
found it um hey welcome to the gang
welcome to the gang I know that's right
hey we're a weird crew and so we welcome
everybody we're glad you're here when
you say weird John are you just talking
about no
all of it all of it very weird but we're
glad to have you we're glad to have you
what's up thank you so um my husband and
I have a bit of debt um I would say he
knows probably about three4 of it um but
he probably doesn't know the amount of
some of it um and having listened to the
show I know that I need to tell him um
but I definitely need to get like a game
plan in place um you know from now
through to retirement he and I are both
state workers in New York work um and
that's like another question mark too as
far as like do we hold out for that
State retirement and stuff but we need
to take care of what is in front of us
first for sure okay big big question
here it sounds like you have some
hesitation to even bring this up to him
am I am I reading into that
wrong a little bit just because um you
know we we've been together for 14 years
um and we are really good um you know
he's he's known about some of the debt
before we've you know kind of taken care
of it together um why do you feel like
don't think sorry you keep saying he's
known about the debt um is it debt that
you're in crewing or is it debt that
you're both in crewing and he's just
kind of mindless about it can you
explain that a little bit Yeah so it's
debt that I'm kind of incre so and it's
kind of twofold um one of them is it's
credit card debt
um and hey does he
know about the credit card debt does he
know how bad it is
is he knows not totally okay here I'm
just going to be super honest with you
okay um yeah what I heard in your voice
when you started talking my mind
immediately went
to if you were having an affair have you
told him the truth about
everything and just a few minutes later
you say now I told him everything so
this conversation has been very much
about him about him about him about him
I think this conversation is very much
about y'all and very much about you and
it sounds like you're tired of not being
fully honest inside your own home with
the man you said I do with is that right
yeah yeah I would say that that's
accurate okay y um what else are you not
telling
him um I mean that's that's kind of the
main thing is the credit card debt how
much is it you know it's probably
hovering around 15 right now okay it's
is he going to be stunned is he going to
be all Angry what's his response going
to be I think he'll be I think he'll be
shocked I think he'll be shocked I mean
we have good jobs like you know I I
think hey I don't care about that this
is this is about you've been keeping
secrets and there's a tension and he's
felt that tension and here's my promise
he has thought in his own weird New York
guy way that that tension was somehow
his fault and he's probably been trying
to fix it for a long time in his weird
way well there might be another side to
that John you think here's here's where
Jade's spring goes and and only Kate is
going to know really where it falls but
I am I'm interested to what sorts of
things are being purchased because
here's the thing when I walk in with a
Target bag my husband's like what'd you
get and I'm like oh yeah I got this
thing or I got this lamp or if I walk in
with the big shopping bag from Zara he's
like oh what'd you get ah so are you
hiding part of me that's wondering is he
not pay attention yeah no he Hees it he
sees it coming in he does for sure um we
have two kids so I do buy stuff for the
kids um you know I I fill up with things
he's seeing the house fill up with
things and he's also not asking
questions so there's there's some things
going on here both end yeah so when you
talk about a game plan the only game
plan game plan I've seen work long term
is you to a change the environment you
got to get them out of your house and
you'll have to go somewhere and have
this conversation because it's going to
be a hard one and you have to say I
haven't been honest with you I haven't
cheated on you I'd get that out there
quick unless you have um no no but I
haven't been honest with you and I want
to come clean and I want us to get on
the same page and start getting safe
with our
money here's the truth and I think
that's the way to start and I think ask
him I'm going to ask you to stay with me
on this I know it's going to be a shock
I know you're going to get upset and
you're right to get upset I've hidden it
from you or maybe like Jade said maybe
he hasn't been a safe place to just come
home and say hey we the kids need some
stuffff yeah and um so there's going
there maybe there's two sides to all
this but somebody has to be courageous
offsite and go here's the truth we got
to build something
new now when I tell you that what is
your body's instant response like no way
or that sounds amazing to have that out
in the honestly it's like my body's
instant response is relief okay perfect
perfect that's awesome then I I want you
to set that up this weekend um and Jade
can walk you through the actual finan
it feels like a million dollars I don't
think you have as much debt as you think
you do I think you have it feels like a
million dollars I know it does but I
think it's the weight of the lack of
Integrity in your home that's what's
Weighing on you more than that dollar
amount yeah um is it just the 15,000 or
is there other debt laying around as
well there's other so what else do you
have so having watched the show having
watched the show I know what's out there
so um so there's about 15 in um credit
card debt uhhuh there is student loans
that are about 30 okay um there are two
other unsecured loans that are about 30
okay there is our cars which call it 50
okay between the two of them can you
break those two down separately for me
car one and car two yeah so mine mine is
about 21 and his is about 30 okay
um is that it or is there there's
more uh we have a home equity loan okay
that we haven't spent all of yet um um
but that when it's done it'll be about
40 and then our mortgage how much is the
mortgage so our mortgage we we have a
lot of Sweat Equity into our house um so
we owe about
220 250 uh 220 okay uh and if we were to
sell it right now I would think we could
get at least 500 for it the reason I was
asking about that line of credit um or
loan that you have through the house is
if it was more than half I would
save it for later but since it's pretty
low I'd add it in with your debt
snowball um which is what you're going
to do to attack this debt now I'm
looking at these vehicles if I'm you do
you do you offhand do you know what
they're
worth mine I'm upside down in uh
unfortunately I carried some negative
equity from the previous vehicle thought
that I was going to get out from under
it with getting something else and I
have not yet yeah if I'm you if I'm you
I'm looking at his vehicle I'm going to
try to get out of it I'm going to try to
get out of yours even if you're up
upside down if you're upside down 5 or
6,000 I'm still probably going to take
the hit and do that you guys have got a
lot to work through John is right it's
about getting out of debt and it's about
holding each other accountable uh going
forward you're not going to get out of
this until you guys agree we're both in
this this debt is both of our issue and
we've got to change our behavior and
hold each other accountable to whatever
plan you guys decide to put in action
this is the ramsy show